Avec le nouvel an, ce qui est bien chaque année, c'est que le comportement des gens, c'est jamais les mêmes
Y a ce mec relou avec l'heure
(tous) 3 ! 2 ! 1 ! Bonne année !!!
Attendez, attendez, je veux pas n*quer l'ambiance mais là, il est pas tout à fait minuit. C'est l'heure de Paris
Là ! Maintenant !!
Y a toujours ce mec qui fait un jeu de mots nul avec l'année
Eh ! 2015, l'année de la bringue ! 2016... l'année de la bringue en 2016 !
Y a ceux qui arrivent à la soirée, mais, un peu trop tôt
Bonne année !
Ah...
Euh, je reviens après, je vais faire un tour en Vélib'
Y a ce mec qui a pas trouvé de soirée
Salut, je m'appelle Bertrand Rocass
On s'était croisée dans la cour en CE2. Tu sais, on avait échangé des Pogs
J'peux vn'ir ? Steuplait
Y a ce mec déçu en arrivant, parce qu'il se rend compte que la soirée est carrément nulle
Bonne année !
Bonne année
Y a ce mec qui se trompe dans le décompte
3... 2... 1...
23 heures
Y a ces mecs qui, sous le prétexte que c'est le Nouvel An
ont vraiment crû qu'ils pouvaient ramener leurs 200 potes à toutes les soirées
Salut, j'suis venu avec... 21 potes
Ça te dérangerait pas de te barrer de chez toi et de nous laisser la baraque ?
Y a ceux qui croient que le SMS de bonne année est vraiment beaucoup plus important que vivre l'instant présent
3 ! 2 ! 1 !
(gars seul) Bonne année ! Bonne année ! Bonne année !
Joël, tu fais quoi là ?
T'es en train de t'amuser ?!
Y a ceux qui veulent absolument être originaux en disant "Bonne année" en anglais
sauf qu'ils parlent pas très bien anglais
Happy new christmas!
Y a toujours ce mec ou cette meuf reloue qui envoie un texto-roman
Stop ! Trop long. On est tous d'accord pour dire que ce genre de textos, euh... on s'en bât les c*uilles
Après vous, je sais pas, mais moi ce genre de texto, j'y réponds souvent comme ça
On va évidemment tous recevoir nos SMS de bonne année en décalé
à cause du réseau qui sature
Ah j'ai reçu un texto c'est bon !
Ah ouais c'est... c'est vraiment décalé
Y a toujours ces numéro inconnus qui t'envoient un SMS de bonne année
Y a ce moment où on se fait tous la bise, sans a priori
en donnant juste de l'amour au premier venu, et c'est ça qui est beau
J'adore t'embrasser
Y a les gens âgés qui aiment bien dire "bonne année"
en langage de gens âgés
Tata et moi te souhaitons une bonne Saint Sylvestre
Tonton, je m'appelle pas Sylvestre
Y a évidemment cette universelle blague de mec un peu lourd
Bon j'ai ramené une bouteille
On l'ouvre l'année prochaine ?
C'est-à-dire dans 10 minutes
Nos grands-parents on les aime à fond tu vois
Mais il faut bien admettre que quand ils nous appellent à 0h05 pour souhaiter la bonne année
y a quand même un petit changement d'ambiance
-- Allô ?
-- C'est mamie
-- Bonjour mamie
Je t'appelle pour te souhaiter une joyeuse année
Tu sais, c'est peut-être la dernière fois que je le fais
L'année prochaine, je serai peut-être plus là qui sait ?
-- D'accord mamie, bonne année.
-- Allez au revoir.
(tous) OUAAIIS !!!!!
Et puis y a ce moment où tu te rends compte que tu passes un réveillon plutôt moyen
quand le premier mec à te souhaiter la bonne année
c'est lui :
Je vous rassure, je vais pas vous faire de roman
Je vous souhaite à tous une très très bonne Saint Sylvestre
Merci à tous d'être encore cette année de plus en plus nombreux à me suivre
à être abonnés à ma chaîne YouTube
Vous êtes plus de 7 millions bientôt
Vous êtes 200 000 à être venus me voir en spectacle
Ça fait un peu phrases à l'eau de rose mais j'm'en fous
Je le dis quand même. Grâce à vous, je fais vraiment un truc que j'aime
Je me réveille, je fais un truc qui me passionne
Et en plus, quand ça vous plaît, c'est 10 fois mieux
Juste un énorme merci
Et puis voilà, je nous souhaite à tous une très bonne année 2016
Bon, on va pas se mentir. Vu ce qu'il s'est passé en France en 2015,
je pense que l'année suivante ne pourra être que meilleure
Enfin j'espère
Du coup mon seul souhait pour 2016
ça serait qu'on passe tous une très bonne année
ou juste une année normale
Voilà, merci à tous. LOVE au max
À très très bientôt, et surtout...
Happy new christmas